in the fields around criviri the long
days of harvest are underway on his 3000
hectares Vladimir Melnick Farms the
crops for which his country is famed the
wheat that provides so much of the
world's bread endless sunflower fields
that make Ukraine the world's biggest
exporter of sunflower seeds
and his barns are filling with canola
oil seed
Black Gold he calls it farming for him
in Wartime he says is an act of service
in my opinion food security means
National Security there's no use crying
over it you need to work think how to
survive and how to win
since the destruction of the khakov
kadam in early June this part of Ukraine
has been struggling to find sufficient
water
mere has had to dig Wells to get the
thousands of liters his farm needs daily
in neighboring small Holdings villagers
struggle to water vegetable gardens upon
which they rely
Arena shows us how low her well is it's
right from the bottom she complains only
the cows can drink it
while vegetable farmer Alexander says he
only has a few weeks water supply
remaining with many of his crops already
parched
as for our vegetables we're still
watering them but we have to hope God
willing for a rainy year we have already
given up on some of the early crops
implementing the grain deal has been
problematic to say the least but it's
meant that in the year since it was
introduced last summer it's helped
Ukraine export 33 million tons of food
which compares favorably with the more
than 50 million tons it was exporting
annually before the war without the deal
Global food prices would have been
higher the world a lot hungrier but
severe restrictions on the number of
ships allowed to carry Ukrainian food
mean Farmers have found other export
routes across land and River boundaries
shipments have increased by rail and
other transport for example we ship
through the Danube yes the deal is
important but it's not essential like
last year
for now gathering in the Harvest and
filling Barns and silos is the priority
questions over how much of Ukraine's
abundant food can be shipped to the
world we'll have to wait Rob McBride Al
Jazeera kriviri Ukraine